wir müssen etwas tun ich bin fest
überzeugt davon wenn man überzeugt ist
dass man handeln muss
dann muss man es zum richtigen zeitpunkt
turm und das tun wir jetzt
ich bedanke mich ausdrücklich bei den
kolleginnen kollegen der freien wähler
heute wieder für das gemeinsame handeln
wir brauchen kein endloses stop and go
wir brauchen keinen halbschlaf sondern
wir brauchen jetzt am ende ein sehr
konsequentes handeln lieber kürzer und
klarer mit mehr perspektiven dann als
ein endlos verlängern
keiner kann sich vorstellen dass die
jetzigen maßnahmen wenn es sich drunter
geht einfach irgendwann bis zu einer
großen angelegten durchimpfung in der
bevölkerung oder impfung erreichen
könnten
der bundesgesundheitsminister darauf
hingewiesen dass er hofft dass bis mitte
nächsten jahres breite impfungen in der
masse stattfinden können so lang kann
aber ein land nicht mit diesen maßnahmen
arbeiten
deswegen ist es bis jetzt klare
entscheidungen zu treffen
konsequenter zu sein die versuche wenn
versucht die menschen aber mitzunehmen
neben dem appell an die
eigenverantwortung brauchte es auch
leitplanken
das was wir heute beschlossen haben ist
alles auf der grundlage der mpk denn wir
haben gesagt dass länder mit hoher
intelligenz und man kann die inzidenz
entwicklung in deutschland sehen
sie wird von nord nach süd deutlich
stärker auf dieser grundlage ist es dass
wir da entschieden haben
ich werde dem landtag am dienstag
vorschlagen das was wir heute
beschlossen haben zur umsetzung der
landtag soll am dienstag darüber
abstimmen sodass es am mittwoch also von
dienstag auf mittwoch zu null uhr dann
greifen würde mit all den maßnahmen
entscheiden dabei auch sie gelten dann
bis 5
januar was haben wir heute beschlossen
neben den bisherigen bestimmungen haben
wir zehn punkte miteinander vereinbart
alles steht unter der überschrift daheim
bleiben einfach daheim bleiben kontakte
reduzieren kontakte vermeiden und
versuchen keine ansteckung weiter zu
verbreiten
das ist die überschrift über ein was
sind die zehn punkte das erste wir rufen
den katastrophenfall erneut aus warum
unabhängig von der tatsache dass die
zahlen jetzt höher sind als im frühjahr
hilft es uns ganz praktisch enorm indem
wir nämlich die gesamte krankenhaus
situation bayernweit besser steuern
können
die überlastete der einen region kann
man viel besser verarbeitet werden
mit den anderen regionen den
krankenhäusern
es ist eine klar eingespielte struktur
hinzu kommt dass die finanzierungsfragen
innerhalb der kommunalen familie damit
besser geregelt sind und auch bei der
denkbaren impfungen die dann ab
möglicherweise ende des jahres
stattfinden kann
bis 15 12 wenn er die 15 drin
fertiggestellt werden können gibt es
dann was die frage der einteilung
beispielsweise auch von ärzten betrifft
eine andere eine bessere eine klage
ordnete regierung allzu erster
katastrophenfall erneut zweiter die
kontakte müssen runter weil die kontakte
runter müssen und weil die zahlen heute
höher sind als im frühjahr im endeffekt
werden wir eine allgemeine ausgangs
beschränkung für ganz bayern
herr vorschlagen allgemeine ausgangs
beschränkung ist nahezu gleich wie im
frühjahr
das heißt nur aus triftigen grund nur
als triftigen grund rausgehen das ist
zum beispiel arbeitsmedizin natürlich
bildung die schule einkaufen oder eben
auch zum beispielsweise familiäre
angelegenheiten nur aus triftigen grund
rausgehen im frühjahr übrigens war
vergleichbar da waren oder unterschiede
im frühjahr das damals auch die
geschäfte geschlossen landwirt uns ist
die situation ziemlich ähnlich wie im
frühjahr zusätzlich zu der ausgangs
beschränkung für ganz bayern werden in
den hot spots ab 200 ab 21 uhr bis 5 uhr
eine ausgangssperre machen
das gleicht sich sehr anders aus
baden-württemberg vorgeschlagen hat
behalten ist für richtig dort wird dann
sozusagen ab 21 uhr bis 5 wollen in hot
spots ab 200 ist eines auch noch einmal
ganz bewusst dazu allen möglichen
zusammen könnten einfach einiges
eindämmung zu erreichen für beide fälle
gilt das bisherige kontaktmanagement
bleibt zwei haushalte maximal fünf
personen kinder unter 14 jahren nicht
das bleibt eine ausnahme gibt es in dem
gesamten monat dezember nur für die zeit
an weihnachten von 23 bis 26
dezember bayern ist ein christlich
geprägtes familienland in dieser zeit
ist uns wichtig dass wir familien feiern
können aber auch damit verantwortung an
dem tag beispielsweise am heiligabend
selber wurde auch bei der ausgangssperre
zum beispiel für die christmesse eine
ausnahme gemacht logischerweise diese
ausnahme der mehr personen gilt nur für
weihnachten nicht für silvester wir uns
ausdrücklich noch einmal überlegt und
abgewogen weihnachten ist das fest der
familie silvester dass das fest mehr der
freunde und der partie das muss in
diesem jahr leider in kleineren kreis
stattfinden
in der genauen regelung maximal fünf
personen zwei haushalte kinder ausgehen
viertens schule
wir müssen es mit der schule noch mal
sehr genau überlegt und haben auch sehr
differenziert argumentiert wir glauben
wir haben in der schule leider bei den
älteren schülern ein höheres geschehen
und auch hier ist ein unglaublich hoher
kontakt verkehr deswegen haben wir
überlegt was können wir tun
klar ist kita und klasse 1 bis 7 bleiben
unbesehen auch förderschulen
aber wir ändern einiges wir wechseln ab
mittwoch komplett in den distanz
unterricht also keine präsenz mehr für
alle berufsschulen in bayern und in den
hotspots hot spots ab 200 ab der achten
klasse also hat mittwoch dann in keiner
berufsschule mehr präsenz im bericht und
in den hotspots auf 200 auch ab der
achten klasse
darüber hinaus wird ab mittwoch in allen
klassen in bayern ab der achten klasse
unabhängig von der inzidenz wechsel
unterricht stattfinden
wir machen es deswegen weil wir damit
insgesamt die kontakte deutlich
reduzieren können
das betrifft ungefähr 550 tausend
schüler ungefähr ein drittel der schüler
damit werden massiv kontakte reduziert
das infektionsgeschehen ist bei dem
älteren schülern und wichtig dabei auch
das entzerrt auch die situation deutlich
im öpnv zwar deutlich einzige ausnahme
übrigens noch das sind die unmittelbare
abschlussklasse die nächsten der
abiturprüfung schreiben
dort muss auch die möglichkeit sein noch
prüfung geschrieben zu werden wie es
nach den ferien weiter geht sehen wir
dann wie die infektions lage ist fünf
geschäfte
wir haben auch darüber geredet es waren
es aber klar dass insbesondere deswegen
weil es auch keine
entschädigungsleistung des bundes geben
kann
die geschäfte offen bleiben aber wir
waren noch einmal sehr deutlich darauf
hinweisen dass die 20 quadratmeter liege
bei den größeren geschäften am 800
quadratmeter also den malls den
einkaufszentren den großen supermärkten
besser überwacht werden muss
die rückmeldung aus dem land bislang
sind so dass es einige gibt die sehr gut
eingehalten haben aber viele
rückmeldungen die wir bekommen haben
über das wochenende war es nicht in der
gleichen weise war im frühjahr darauf
hingewirkt werden durch entsprechende
kontrollen gespräche auch mit den
entsprechenden verbänden
klar ist auch wir wollen auch keine
gruppenbildung den städten haben
einkaufen ja das sind wird alkoholkonsum
auf öffentlichen plätzen künftig
ausgeschlossen
6 der grenzverkehr
wir haben erlebt gerade in bayern dass
der grenzverkehr eine herausforderung
ist die grenze soll offen bleiben das
ist das gemeinschaftliche europäische
ziel aber wir müssen hier auch
einschränkungen vornehmen
der sogenannte kleine grenzverkehr der
können die kleine grenzverkehr wird
ausgesetzt
was bedeutet es nicht für pendler oder
familien ersten und zweiten grades dort
kann man die grenze überqueren ohne
einen test oder eine quarantäne zu
brauchen aber bei allen anderen muss
dann ein entsprechender test vorliegen
ein negativer tests oder er in die
quarantäne geheilt werden
dies trifft insbesondere einkaufen
freizeit und alles andere als wir
schränken den kleinen grenzverkehr ein
und reduzieren das einer der hauptgründe
im eintrag auch im über die grenze merkt
man aber bei dem einen pendler
insbesondere im bereich der pflege
damit bin ich bei punkt sieben alten und
pflegeheimen behinderteneinrichtungen
die sind zum teil hotspots in den
ortsbus unter finden zum teil tragödien
stadt die höchste zahl der todesfälle
findet hier statt
deswegen werden wir uns dem thema noch
mal
ganz bewusst und ganz konzentriert
widmen
wir haben nochmal das
gesundheitsministerium wahrgenommen die
heimaufsicht sehr massiv wahrzunehmen
drei dinge werden jetzt hier noch einmal
präzisiert erstens besucher einer pro
tag getestet und mit sp2 maske
mitarbeiter müssen zweimal die woche
einen test ablegen
zweimal die woche und alle natürlich mit
sp2 masken es soll übrigens nicht nur
schnell test sein wir sitzen hier auch
auf pcr tests weil die noch mehr
sicherheit gewinnen und was wichtig ist
bei entsprechenden infektionen
dann ist zb in passau an das village das
ist eine der haupt eintrags quellen ist
auch für die inzidenz bei entsprechendem
ausbruch von erkrankungen sollte soweit
es möglich ist auch hier hilft an der k
fall die abwägung stattfinden und die
verlegung in entsprechende quarantäne
reha-einrichtungen die dann dort
stattfinden können um das
infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren bei
krankenhäusern übrigens werden wir auch
für die besucher eine verpflichtung
vorschlagen für die ffb zwei maske
achter
die gesundheitsämter ist etwas kleinere
so wichtiges werden jetzt einheitlich
angewiesen eine einheitliche software zu
verwenden die vom bund gestellt wird es
gibt die klare verpflichtung allen
hotspots bundes wären polizei
anzufordern um die nachverfolgung zu
gewährleisten
die argumentation die nachverfolgung und
gesundheit in der seite der höhe nicht
mehr leistbar wird damit klar geregelt
es wird entsprechendes personal
angefordert und zehntes und letztes wir
appellieren an alle arbeitgeber home
office zu machen wo es nur geht und auch
über die weihnachtsferien so viel
freiheit wie möglich zu schaffen das
auch da alle daheim bleiben können für
den staat selber wir werden noch einmal
unsere gesamte home office quote
deutlich erhöhen
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass die
präsenz in den behörden
über die weihnachtsfeier zeit soweit ist
geht reduziert wird ausnahme natürliches
polizei und alles was systemrelevant ist
wie gesundheitsdienste und
gesundheitsämter und alle diese fragen
zieht punkte
wichtig ist vor allem dass die
überschrift kontakte reduzieren
daheim bleiben ich weiß das sind
entbehrungen erneut immer wieder so geht
es nicht nur den bayern so geht es der
welt kroner lässt einfach nicht locker
mir war auch nicht wir geben uns diesem
virus nicht geschlagen sondern wir
reagieren
es sind mehr infiziert das im frühjahr
das müssen wir in ähnlicher weise
reagieren wir haben schon einmal
erfolgreich
diese herausforderung bestanden und
getrotzt wir müssen nicht alles gleich
machen aber vieles ähnlich weshalb auch
gewirkt und es ist sinnvoll ist jetzt
auch vor weihnachten zu tun
es gibt die eine andere empfehlung die
sagt lass uns über weihnachten neujahr
dann einfach alles machen das ist mir zu
spät
das ist uns zu spät wir brauchen jetzt
entscheidungen um das level zu senken
und vielleicht irgendwann wieder die
hoffnung zu vermitteln dass ab januar
dass ein anderer besser werden könnte
wir werden sehen ob es dann soweit ist
klar ist die ferien werden eine große
herausforderung für diese ferien
vorbereitet zu sein und auch die zahl
der todesfälle zu reduzieren ist das
gebot der stunde
jetzt habe nicht wahr es gibt hoffnung
dass sind der impfstoff wir bereiten uns
akribisch genau worauf die impfzentren
aber jeder muss wissen das ist kein
zauber frank oder wundermittel wo über
nacht alle probleme gelöst sind
es wird noch eine menge rechtlicher
fragen geben die es in diesen zusammen
zu lösen gilt nicht nur wer dran ist
geimpft zu werden sondern auch die frage
wie geht man damit um wenn jemand
geimpft ist wie werden die allgemeinen
regeln angewandt und bei der
debattenkultur die wir derzeit in
deutschland haben wo alles grundlegend
neu herausgefordert wird wird es nicht
einfach sein
trotzdem das ist sicher eine hoffnung es
ist ein licht
aber es ist kein grelles
scheinwerferlicht auf das wird zum
laufen
das muss jedem klar sein jedenfalls hier
sind überzeugung wie gesagt noch mal
danke schön an allen die heute mit
gemerkt haben dass es besser ist
konsequent und klar zu handeln als
einfach zu warten und zu hoffen es wird
nun besser hoffnung ist gut handeln es
besser ich bitte alle bürgern und bürger
des freistaats bei einverständnis
wir sind stärker betroffen als der rest
in deutschland und die meisten anderen
länder also müsse noch mehr tun kann man
nicht einfach zuschauen
die gründe dafür sind mannigfaltig das
hat sicherlich was mit grenzen zu tun
aber nicht nur deswegen meint bitte dass
wir uns nicht nur die regeln halten
jeder kann sogar ein bisschen mehr tun
aber wir brauchen umgekehrt auch
leitplanken
wir behalten die nerven wir behalten die
ruhe und wir gehen unseren weg in der
hoffnung dass das auch impuls sagen ich
bin übrigens der festen überzeugung wir
werden wahrscheinlich noch einmal eine
minister sind konferenz vor weihnachten
brauchen in dem wir uns auch noch mal
klarer unterhalten was an weihnachten
und neujahr stattfindet denn ich denke
den meisten geht es so wie mir in
deutschland ist es auch so die zahl
derer die nach konsequenten maßnahmen an
konsequente maßnahmen ding wächst
und ich glaube wir sollten auch die
sorgen gerne aufnehmen mitnehmen und
dann umsetzen
vielen dank wir sind bild und wie er
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren